Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and because Doctor
Who is coming back and a lot of you found
me because of other shows I wanted to do a
video explaining where to start if you’ve
never seen it before and why it is the most
fun hour you will ever spend watching something
every week. I’m also starting my weekly
Doctor Who giveaway. All you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video.
It’s just a $20 amazon gift card. Why not
have fun talking about sci fi and win free
shit at the same time.
People are calling Guardians of the Galaxy
the most fun Marvel movie so far. Think of
Doctor Who as being like the most fun science
fiction you’ve ever watched.
I’m going to be doing the same type of videos
I did for Game of Thrones this year when episodes
start. That’s Saturday August 23rd.
You can watch the first episode in cinemas
all over the world. I’ll add a link for
where to find one near you in the description.
So most important thing first. Series 8 is
a very big deal because it’s a brand new
actor playing the Doctor, Peter Capaldi. Each
new actor that takes on the role honors previous
Doctors with catch phrases or affectations
or the clothes they wear. It just had it’s
50th Anniversary last year, so there’s a
pretty deep well of character traits to draw
from.
That’s also part of the reason Doctor Who
fandom exists in this special pantheon up
there with things like Lord of the Rings and
Star Wars. Everybody has their quote unquote
Doctor, the actor that introduced them to
the franchise. Which is why no one can agree
on who the best Doctor is. That’s okay.
One of the reasons I love it is because I
really love Fantasy, Science Fiction, Horror,
Drama, all genres. And when you watch a show
like Game of Thrones, it treats the material
and the genre very seriously. Doctor Who on
the other hand jumps all over genres each
episode.
Like you can go from hard sci-fi with a story
like The Doctor traveling to the end of the
Universe or traveling outside normal space
to interact with creatures the size of asteroids.
But there was one episode when Matt Smith
was still the Doctor where they two Harry
Potter actors and dinosaurs on a space ship.
And unless you were made of stone, you ended
up crying when
one of the dinosaurs died.
By the way, those Harry Potter actors were
Mark Williams who was Arthur Weasley and David
Bradley who was Argus Filch, he also plays
Walder Frey on Game of Thrones. It’s not
something you think about all the time. But
being on Doctor Who is something of a watermark
That’s another good way to think about it,
Doctor Who does stories that cross a lot of
fandom streams.
The biggest new thing about Series 8 is Peter
Capaldi. When a new actor comes on, the whole
tone of the show changes and just as the Doctor
regenerates into a new body, the show in a
meta sense, regenerates itself. When Matt
Smith was the Doctor there wa a lot of relationship
comedy, just because he was so young.
Peter Capaldi is the oldest person to play
the Doctor next to John Hurt. So now the thought
is based on what people are saying, that the
show will look more like classic sci fi horror.
When I think sci-fi horror I mostly think
of Sigourney Weaver in the first Alien movie.
But since Doctor Who jumps from genre to genre.
You can expect a lot of different types of
scary stories.
The tag line for the first big trailer was
Doctor Who Into Darkness. Which for me was
probably the most exciting thing the BBC could
have put in that trailer.
There is a large rotating cast of companions
and secondary characters. Companions are people
who travel with the Doctor, there are usually
only a couple of them around at any one time
and right now Clara Oswald is the only one.
But supposedly there’s going to be a few
new ones coming after the first few episodes.
The secondary characters and villains are
usually where you see the famous British stars
showing up. When they cast someone who’s
really well known or someone who’s already
a really established actor. Usually they get
a really amazing character to play.
Peter Capaldi, the person who’s the new
Doctor was actually a big guest star when
David Tennant was playing the Doctor. It’s
a pretty big easter egg for the fandom and
now everyone’s wondering if Capaldi’s
earlier character will have anything to do
with the story this year.
In case you’ve never watched Doctor Who
or you just want to reboot your brain before
episode 1 airs. Here’s the tv you need to
watch and where to find the episodes:
First off, don’t worry about watching other
Doctor’s seasons, like Matt Smith. You can
totally jump on cold turkey. But you should
at least watch some other Peter Capaldi stuff.
Namely In The Thick of it. There are 23 episodes
all on Hulu right now. They’re all free.
You don’t need hulu plus.
Capaldi plays this character called Malcolm
Tucker and he has the most foul mouth you’ve
ever heard. It’s hilarious. If you do a
search for him on tumblr. It’s all gifs
of him dropping f-bombs. It’s so great.
Next, watch Torchwood Children of the Earth.
Capaldi plays another morally ambiguous person
of authority who’s forced to do some really
awful things in the name of survival. This
one is also on Hulu, it’s Torchwood Season
3. But it’s only available on Hulu plus.
It’s also available on Netflix.
Then you should check out his previous episode
of Doctor Who. It’s Series 4 episode 2.
It’s also only available on Hulu plus and
Netflix. But it also stars Karen Gillan in
a different role before she became a full
time companion during Matt Smith’s run.
She’s in full body makeup like she is in
Guardians of The Galaxy. So see if you can
spot her.
After you get a sense for Peter Capaldi you
can check out the really important older episodes.
Which are all both on Netflix and Hulu.
Here’s a list of five that I think are going
to inform some of what happens in the new
episodes.
First, for an introduction into the show’s
core concepts, from Series 1 there’s
Episode 2 - The End of The World
Episodes 9 and 10 - Empty Child and The Doctor
Dances
and Episodes 11 and 12 - Bad Wolf and Parting
of Ways
That’s like the cliff’s notes for everything
Doctor Who
Then when you get through that check out Series
Episode 2 School Reunion,
Episodes 5 and 6 Rise of The Cybermen and
Age of Steel
Series 3 Episode 10 Blink - hello weeping
angels
The TV Special The End of Time - So you can
learn all about the Master
Then moving on, Series 5 episode 10 - Vincent
and the Doctor. One of the finest episodes
of Doctor Who ever.
The 2012 christmas special, The Snowmen. and
then to learn all about the current companion
clara, all of the episodes in series 7 part
and all of the specials surrounding the 50th
anniversary including the night of the doctor
that one’s free on youtube I’ll add a
link in the description, the day of the doctor
and the time of the doctor. That was when
Matt Smith regenerated into peter capaldi.
That’s a pretty long list, so if you feel
like you don’t have it in you to watch everything.
You can just watch the peter capaldi stuff
I mentioned and the episodes in series 1 I
listed.
I’ll add a link to all this in the description.
I’ll do a tumblr post where I link to each
of the episodes on Hulu and Netflix just to
make it easier. I have links to twitter and
facebook down there too. I’ll post the list
everywhere.
Here’s details on the videos I’ll be doing.
Because part of the fun of doctor who is looking
for easter eggs and references to old episodes.
When I do review videos I’ll try to include
as much of that as possible. I’ll also be
doing bonus videos explaining characters and
other things I think are really interesting
and Q&As to follow up on anything you guys
want to spend more time talking about.
There are only a couple of places you can
watch new episodes when the first air. For
UK people, there’s BBC One, for People in
the US there’s BBC America, then there’s
SkyOne in Canada.
There’s not a lot of good info on the BBCs
website about where it airs in other international
countries. But just check your local listings.
It’s supposed to air pretty close to the
same time everywhere all over the world. So
no matter where you live you shouldn’t have
to wait too long.
You can also try to stream it if you live
in a country that does not get Doctor Who,
but because that’s technically illegal,
I won’t allow any stream links in the comments.
But if that’s how you watch TV, more power
to you. Just continue to watch it that way.
I’m so excited you guys have no idea. This
is going to be a fun series. I actually just
quit my job last month and I timed my last
day to be the week before Doctor Who comes
back. Just so I would have a week to move
to a new apartment and prepare myself.
Doctor Who was the first video I did on my
channel when I started it. It was for the
2012 christmas special. Please don’t watch
that video. It’s embarrassing.
Right now click here for a breakdown of the
last trailer and click here to learn about
some of the new characters coming.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!